course we got two discret results We performed the experiment on a digital quantum computer which only ever returns
zero or one and this is true but keep in mind that the entire reason quantum computers return binary results in fact
why Quantum Computing works at all is exactly because this spin quantization that Stern and gerlock first discovered
the cubits in IBM quantum computers are not based on spins but many other quantum computers are so performing a
Stern gerlock experiment on a quantum computer allows us to actually ReDiscover spin quantization
since 1922 countless extensions to the original Stern gerlock experiment have been performed these extensions involve
sending the same beam of atoms through multiple Stern gerlock apparatuses to see how the spins behave in different
scenarios here's one let's send the atoms through one apparatus to separate the beam into two corresponding to a
spin up beam and a spin down beam and then send each of those beams through their own separate
apparatuses with kcit the quantum circuit corresponding to this experiment is similar to the last one but with two
measurements instead of one here we've replaced the random rotations that mimicked the effect of the oven with a
gate called a hadamard since applying the hadamard will give us the same measurement probabilities as the oven
did but it's much simpler to use so we measure once and then twice and the
resulting measurement histogram for the experiment looks like this where the bit strings on the X AIS correspond to the
outcomes of the two measurements if the Cubit was measured zero both times that corresponds to the 0 0 bit string or if
it was measured first zero then one that corresponds to one Zer and so on it looks like if it was measured spin up in
the first experiment it will be spin up in the second same with the spin down atoms that means in the first experiment
we had equal ability of measuring up or down but by the second experiment the outcome was already determined so the
two screens at the end of each of the second Stern GAC apparatuses would each only have one spot one screen would have
all the spin up atoms and one screen would have all the spin down atoms for our next experiment let's
start with a beam of purely spin up atoms with an actual physical Stern GAC experiment you could do this by sending
them through a Stern GAC apparatus and blocking the beam that's deflected down so all the atoms deflected upward are
spin up now let's send this beam through another Stern gerlock apparatus but this time let's rotate the magnets 90° so
that the field gradient will deflect the atoms that are traveling this way to the left or to the right instead would we
see one spot or two or something completely different for this experiment
we'll run the following circuit on kcit we'll start in the zero State since our beam of atoms in this experiment are all
spin up then this hadamard gate exchanges the x and z coordinates so that it has the effect of rotating the
stern GAC apparatus so now we're measuring the spin projection left or right instead of up or down here we get
the measurement histogram that looks like this so we can see that the spin along X can also only take on two values
which we can call spin left and spin right so this experiment shows that if you measure the X projection of a spin
that was previously measured to be spin up along Z it will be spin left or right with equal probability let's contrast
this one last time to classical expectation just to really highlight the difference classically remember that I
said that if the little Atomic bar magnet was pointing perpendicular to the magnetic field gradient of the apparatus
the force on that atom should be zero it shouldn't be deflected up or down in that case we just see a single spot in
the middle of the screen instead we see two spots so half the atoms have spin left and half have spin right even
though they were previously measured to be up so from a quantum mechanical perspective while it may be tempting to
equate spin up with a vector pointing up and spin down with one pointing down it's not as simple as this as we can see
from the last experiment to really understand what's going on here we'll need to go deeper into the topics of
quantum superposition and measurement which will be a video for another day just as we're left with more
questions about how exactly quantum mechanics works so were Stern and gerlock their experiment didn't explain
everything but it went a long way in establishing quantum mechanics as essential to understanding the natural
world it was one of the most important foundational experiments in quantum mechanics that both proved quantization
of momentum and provided evidence for a new fundamental property of nature called spin to really grapple with and
understand the rules of the quantum World physicists like Stern and gerlock had to get their hands dirty designing
experiments making predictions and sometimes being wrong there really is no replacement for trying things yourself
so if you want to try your hand at running some real Quantum experiments head over to the stern gerlock module
Linked In the description thanks for watching and I'll see you next time